okay I see you filled in form B10
2011a request for additional apparatus
or equipment within the Street Fighter 2
tournament herein also known as sf2 and
sf2 special Champion
okay fighting card filled in your name
is Mr Vega Vega Mr Vega what is it uh
exactly you would like to bring into the
ring with you other than your other than
your body I would like to fight with
this enormous sharp metal
[Music]
claw I'm sorry this enormous claw this
one that I'm that I'm wearing right now
I want to fight with it okay Mr Vega
Vega Vega this is a street fighting
tournament martial arts Kung Fu brawling
do you understand contestants are
allowed to bring in say uh shinguards or
uh hand wrap
sweatfit are you honestly saying you
want to go out there against contestants
wearing a 18in three bladed
claw yes well well pardon my language uh
but but are you [__] kidding
me are you just straight up [__] out
of your goddamn mind
[__] I cannot have my claw no no you
can't enter a a street fighting
tournament against unarmed Fighters and
just start mauling them with a [__]
razor sharp Claw is that what you
thought you were going to do but some of
the fighters they throw fire from their
hands yeah that's called a fireball do
you know how hard it is to summon your
Chi and produce one it just out of
nothing do you have any idea how hard it
is to learn that a lot harder than going
to a store and buying a [__] cloth a
I'll tell you that right
now what is it was that your thing hi hi
everybody I'm
Vega I'm not good at fighting so I'll
just tape some knives to my hand that'll
that'll sharpen my chances
huh that's your thing why don't why not
just buy a [__] gun let's enter the
round one bang oh perfect you win bang
Ultra Combo go fck
yourself and
[__] bison bison said I could I'm
sorry
what bison M bison said that bison yes
don't [__] me no it's true he said
all right well let's just check out this
little colorful story you're telling me
right now
let's see if that hello Mr bison hi
sorry it's Steve down in Administration
I'm with a Mr
Vega he's telling me that you said it
was uh okay for him to wear a
claw it
is yes yes sir yes sir I know I I I
can't compare with your
powers yes sir anyone who opposes you
will be
destroyed yep y very very handsome
okay okay checks out out you can use the
claw okay we're done you can go oh that
is that's not all what that's not all
what else could there possibly be I want
to fight with this mask
on you [__] suck you know
that